>> Sandra: THE HOUSE PASSING A
CORONAVIRUS RELIEF BILL AT 1
A.M. SATURDAY MORNING AFTER
DRAWN OUT NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI AND
TREASURY SECRETARY STEVE
MNUCHIN.
>> Ed: THE PRESIDENT IS EXPECTED
TO SIGN THE DEAL.
FIRST IT HAS TO PASS THROUGH THE
SENATE.
A SENIOR REPUBLICAN SOURCE TOLD
FOX NOT TO UNDER-ESTIMATE THE
CHALLENGES THE BILL COULD FACE
IN THE SENATE.
LET’S BRING IN OUR HEADLINER
TEXAS CONGRESSMAN MICHAEL
MCCALL.
RANKING MEMBER OF THE HOUSE
FOREIGN AFFAIRS COMMITTEE.
YOU VOTED FOR THIS PACKAGE IN
THE WEE HOURS SATURDAY MORNING.
A LOT OF REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES
WERE NOT HAPPY THEY WERE HANDED
AT THE LAST-MINUTE AND THERE MAY
BE TECHNICAL CORRECTIONS BECAUSE
IT WAS PASSED WITH SUCH HASTE.
IF THIS IS TROUBLE IN THE
SENATE, WHAT NEXT, SIR?
>> THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
WE NEED TO MOVE QUICKLY.
WE DON’T HAVE THE LUXURY OF
TIME.
HI THE SAME CONCERNS.
IT WAS THROWN TOGETHER.
I WILL SAY THE VERSION NANCY
PELOSI DROPPED THE NIGHT THE
RULES COMMITTEE VERSUS WHAT WE
VOTED ON THE FLOOR CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY.
THAT’S BECAUSE SECRETARY MNUCHIN
AND THE WHITE HOUSE WERE ABLE TO
NEGOTIATE A FAR BETTER BILL ON
THIS ISSUE.
I THINK WHAT IT DOES, ED, IT
GETS TESTING OUT TO EVERYONE IN
AMERICA WHO NEEDS IT FREE OF
COST.
WE ARE GETTING READY TO MOVE
INTO THE NEXT 2 MONTHS WHICH
WILL GET WORSE AND NOT BETTER.
WE ARE MOVING FROM CONTAINMENT
TO COMMUNITY SPREAD ILLNESS.
THIS IS NOT A TIME TO WAIT
AROUND.
WE NEED ACTION RIGHT NOW FROM
THE CONGRESS.
THIS PROVIDES THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE AND IT PROVIDES SCHOOL
MEALS TO KIDS WHO CAN’T GO TO
SCHOOL.
THE SOCIAL DISTANCING FACTOR, IF
I COULD SAY IS PROBABLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT ELEMENT WE NEED TO
TALK ABOUT TO TRY TO KEEP WHAT
THE DOCTOR FROM THE NIH TALKED
ABOUT.
KEEPING THIS CURVE FLAT.
THE NEXT 2 MONTHS ARE CRITICAL
WITH THIS DISEASE AS WE SAW IN
SOUTH KOREA AND ITALY.
TWO DIFFERENT MODELS.
WE WANT TO FOLLOW THE SOUTH
KOREA MODEL.
MORE TESTING AND FLATTEN THIS
CURVE SO WE DON’T HAVE CASES
INCREASE.
>> Sandra: WITH THE TESTING OR
THE CHANGES TO TRAVEL, THE
PRESIDENT’S EUROPEAN TRAVEL BAN
TAKING EFFECT.
OVER THE WEEKEND CROWDS OF
PEOPLE, YOU TALK ABOUT SOCIAL
DISTANCING HOW IMPORTANT IT IS.
BUT AIRPORTS WERE FLOODED WITH
PEOPLE IN MASSIVE CROWDS.
STANDING IN LINE FOR HOURS.
ARE WE DEPLOYING THESE TACTICS
IN THE BEST WAY POSSIBLE?
>> WELL, I THINK WE CAN DO
BETTER.
I TALKED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY AND I  CHAIRED
THE COMMITTEE FOR 6 YEARS.
DFW WAS A NIGHTMARE.
THEY HAVE TO GO THROUGH MEDICAL
SCREENINGS AND WAITING IN LINE
FOR HOURS WITH THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE.
TALKING ABOUT SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND THE NIH AND CDC IS TALKING
ABOUT THIS BUT THESE PEOPLE WERE
HELD UP IN LINES AT AIRPORT LIKE
A PETRY DISH.
THAT HAS TO BE CORRECTED.
THEY WILL PUT MORE PPLE ON
OVERTIME -- AND BRING NEW
MEDICAL SCREENERS IN TO GET THAT
PROCESS MOVING FAR MORE QUICKLY.
>> Ed: THINKYOU USED TO BE THE C
OF THE HOMELAND SECURITY
COMMITTEE.
YOU SEE THAT CHAOS AT AIRPORTS.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOCUSSED
ON THIS HEALTH CRISIS.
HOW CONCERNED WITH YOU ABOUT BAD
ACTORS AROUND THE WORLD TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THE UNITED STATES
AT A MOMENT LIKE THIS?
>> WELL, I DON’T THINK THE
PRESIDENT IS GETTING ENOUGH
CREDIT FOR SHUTTING DOWN PEOPLE
COMING IN FROM CHINA.
RIGHT OUT OF THE BOX HE SAID
THEY COULD NOT COME INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
AMERICANS ARE IN A DIFFERENT
POSITION.
HE ALSO SCREENED PASSENGER FROM
SOUTH KOREA.
ITALY AND NOW A TRAVEL BAN ON
EUROPE.
THESE ARE AGGRESSIVE TACTICS.
THEY ARE NECESSARY TO PROTECT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE FROM ACTORS
COMING IN WHETHER IT’S SOMEBODY
NOT KNOWING THEY HAVE THE VIRUS
VERSUS PEOPLE KNOWING THEY HAVE
IT.
AND WE LOOK AT BIO-TERRORISM.
THIS IS ALWAYS AN ISSUE AT THE
BORDER NOT FAR FROM WHERE I AM
SITTING HERE TODAY.
WE HAVE TO STOP THIS VIRUS AND
CONTAIN IT FROM COME INTO UNITED
STATES.
NOW THAT IT’S HERE.
WE HAVE TO FLATTEN THE CURVE AND
MAKE SURE IT DOESN’T SPREAD TO
MORE AND MORE AMERICANS.
THE NEXT 2 MONTHS ARE CRITICAL.
AS WE MOVE INTO THE SUMMER, YOU
WILL SEE A PHASING DOWN OF CASES
BY SUMMER.
>> Sandra: WE JUST DON’T KNOW
WHAT IS HAPPENING NEXT.
WE CAN LOOK AT MARKETS THIS
MORNING.
YOU SAW A TRADING HALT HAD TO
HAPPEN BECAUSE CIRCUIT BREAKERS
WERE TRIGGERED.
SENATOR ON FOX AND FRIENDS
YESTERDAY, SHE WAS TALKING ABOUT
WHAT CAN BE DONE TO MITIGATE THE
ECONOMIC IMPACT.
>> WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT THE
ENTIRE SUPPLY CHANGE.
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE CRUISE
LINES.
WHAT ABOUT THE DOCKWORKERS AND
THE ENTERTAINERS OR SPEAKERS WHO
LOST THEIR BOOKINGS ON CRUISES.
SEVERAL FROM NASHVILLE CALLED
AND ASKED ME ABOUT THIS.
THEY DON’T WANT THE BURDEN TO
END UP ON SMALL BUSINESS
DISBLAURND .
>> Sandra: YOU ARE FIELDING
QUESTIONS AS WELL.
>> THERE IS A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY.
THEY ARE RESPONDING NEGATIVELY.
TALKING TO PEOPLE LIKE LARRY,
THE FUNDAMENTALS IN OUR ECONOMY
ARE STILL STRONG.
THAT’S WHY WE ARE GET THROUGH
THIS THING.
IT WILL IMPACT THE MARKET.
I WORRY ABOUT THE ENTERTAINMENT
AND ALSO THE AIRLINES TALKING
ABOUT GOING INTO BANKRUPTCY BY
MAY.
IF I CAN SAY THERE ARE TWO MORE
POSITIVE THINGS THAT CAME OUT
RECENTLY I HOPE GIVE THE MARKETS
MORE REASSURANCE.
ANTI-VIRALS, THREE ARE BEING
TESTED IN CHINA ON CHINESE
PATIENTS THAT HAVE SHOWN GREAT
PROMISE.
WE ARE GETTING A REPORT IN APRIL
ABOUT THAT.
AND THE FIRST CLINICAL TRIAL
VACCINE IS BEING TESTED TODAY IN
SEATTLE, WASHINGTON.
IT WILL STILL TAKE A YEAR TO
FINALIZE THAT.
THAT’S SOME POSITIVE NEWS.
WE HAVE TO REASSURE THE MARKETS
THIS WON’T SPIRAL OUT OF
CONTROL.
THAT’S WHY THAT BILL IS
IMPORTANT TO PASS.
IT WILL GIVE CERTAINTY TO
MARKETS AND PROVIDE TESTING WE
NEED THROUGHOUT THE UNITED
STATES.
>> Ed: THE BILL YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT IN THE SENATE’S HANDS NOW.
MAYBE PHASE-1.
OTHERS SAY PHASE-2 BECAUSE $8
BILLION WAS SPENT THE PREVIOUS
WEEK.
WHO DO YOU SEE IN TERMS OF HOW
MANY MORE PHASES WE MAY AND
HELPING AIRLINES AND HOTEL AND
THE CRUISE INDUSTRY?
>> I AM NOT A FAN OF BAILOUTS.
I VOTED AGAINST IT BACK IN THE
CRISIS BACK THEN.
I WILL SAY WE PASSED $8 BILLION
FOR RESEARCH FOR TREATMENTS.
THE LAST BILL IS FOR FAMILIES
FIRST TO GET SCREENING AND PAID
SICK LEAVE.
THINGS THAT EVERY DAY AMERICANS
ARE WORRIED ABOUT.
THERE WILL BE A 3rd PHASE COMING
OUT TO DEAL WITH THE TAX CUTS WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT TO PROVIDE TO
PEOPLE AT MIDDLE TO LOW-INCOME
ON THEIR PAYROLL TAX TO KEEP
MORE OF WHAT THEY EARN AND PUT
IT BACK IN THE ECONOMY.
OUR FUNDAMENTALS ARE STRONG.
THAT’S IMPORTANT TO SAY.
THIS IS A CURVEBALL FROM WUHAN,
CHINA.
WE HAVE TO GET OFF THE SUPPLY
CHAIN OF SHINE.
-- CHINA.
IT’S NOT GOOD FOR THE UNITED
STATES.
>> Ed: A LOT OF BIG ISSUES AND
THE HEALTH CRISIS IS FIRST AND